[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe kollegen
zum zweiten mal in diesem jahr beraten
wir über den entwurf eines
bundeshaushalts dazugelernt hat ihre
regierung seither nichts frau
bundeskanzlerin sie betreiben weiterhin
eine politik der spaltung und der
unvernunft eine politik des ausgaben
wahns und der falschen prioritäten eine
politik die den noch vorhandenen
wohlstand von heute bedenkenlos mit
vollen händen ausgibt und verschleudert
ohne an morgen zu denken
geändert hat sich aber die ökonomische
grundlage auf der sie diesen ausverkauf
betreiben das wirtschaftliche fundament
rocket ihre politik ignoriert konsequent
die ökonomische vernunft sie sehr zäh
interessen des eigenen landes und der
eigenen bürger an die letzte stelle
dafür rennen sie aber ideologischen welt
beglückung fantasien hinterher und das
hält eben auch wie stärkste
volkswirtschaft auf dauer nicht ohne
schaden aus
die automobilindustrie die
automobilindustrie ein eckpfeiler
unserer volkswirtschaft gerät in die
krise die absätze brechen auf breiter
front ein
das wirtschaftswachstum in deutschland
ist erstmals seit jahren wieder
rückgängig
kein wunder wenn die politik jahrelang
einen regelrechten krieg gegen den
verbrennungsmotor führt unsinnige
emissionsgrenzwerte durch peitscht und
obskuren lobbyvereinen die möglichkeit
gibt ein fahrverbot nach den andern
einzuklagen
in der wirtschaft und energiepolitik
schreiben sie nur um atomausstieg
kohleausstieg hoch subventionierte
alternativen energien die nicht
grundlastfähig sind hochgejubelte
elektroautos die für massenmobilität
überhaupt nicht tauglich sind
und vielleicht erzählt uns ja ihr neu
gegründeter parlamentskreis fährt das
ist ja unglaublich habe es nicht
geglaubt als ich das gehört habe ihr
parlamentskreis fährt welche
fortbewegungsmittel wir künftig
überhaupt noch nutzen dürfen wenn
deutschland erfolgreich zum
klimaneutralen agrar land
heruntergewirtschaftet wurde schlechte
wirtschaftspolitik schlechte
wirtschaftspolitik ist eben auch
schlechte sozialpolitik und die trifft
immer zuerst die normalbürger die
arbeiten und steuern zahlen
sie werden nach strich und faden
ausgenommen wie eine weihnachtsgans
schreien sie nur ich weiß getroffene
hunde bellen durch den wertverlust ihrer
autos und durch hohe energiekosten durch
hoch steuerpolitik und ezb nullzins
während die verbraucherpreise kräftig
steigen so werden die normalbürger
ausgenommen nur der unfassbaren
disziplin und geduld der deutschen ist
es überhaupt zu verdanken dass es auch
keine flächendeckenden massenproteste
gibt wie in frankreich
der aufstand der gelben westen gegen die
neueste spritpreiserhöhung noch nie in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland hatte die öffentliche hand
so viel vom bürger zur verfügung und
noch nie wurde so viel geld so schlecht
ausgegeben wir haben eine
vernachlässigte armee
ihren auftrag der landesverteidigung
nicht erfüllen kann
deren panzer nicht fahren schiffe nicht
in see stechen flugzeuge und
hubschrauber nicht fliegen und die
trotzdem in immer neue einsätze in aller
welt geschickt werden wir leisten uns
eine gigantische sozial industrie mit
einer wuchernden doppelstruktur aus
staatlichen und nichtstaatlichen
akteuren die vor allem sich selbst
helfen kann an ericsson statt nein nicht
noch mal da auf der ecke am
allerwenigsten sie kommen gleich noch
dran ja am allerwenigsten aber nützen
sie denen für deren staatliche
zwangsbeglückung sie angeblich
geschaffen wurden
wir geben jedes jahr geld für den kampf
gegen rechts aus und andere bevormundung
der bürger aber frauen und mädchen
können sich ja abends gar nicht mehr
allein auf die straße wagen aus furcht
vor übergriffen sogenannter schutz
suchen wir vertrauen im eigenen land gut
ausgebildete fachkräfte mit schlechten
arbeitsbedingungen und miserable
bezahlung ins ausland und suchen unser
heil in der anwerbung ausländischer
fachkräfte die in ihren eigenen ländern
dringend gebraucht würden sofern sie
denn überhaupt fachkräfte sind und ich
merke schon ihrem ganzen geschrei
entnehme ich dass sie lieber über
spenden und portal finanzierung reden
wollen also wird
wenn wir darüber ja es ist richtig es
ist richtig dass bei uns fehler im
umgang mit wahlkampfspenden gemacht
wurden
das kann passieren wenn man alles
ehrenamtlich macht und keine
parteifunktionär strukturen hat wie sie
fehler macht schließlich jeder
richtig ist aber auch richtig ist aber
auch dass sich niemand persönlich
bereichert hat
es wurde auch nichts versucht zu
verschleiern
ja man ist ganz normale partei konnten
gewesen sind über die rechenschaft
abgelegt werden muss richtig ist auch
dass die gelder zurück überwiesen wurden
auch was ganz besonderes unserer partei
es wurden auch keine bargeld kopf hin
und her getragen deren inhalt in
schubladen verschwunden ist und an deren
verbleibt sich niemand mehr erinnern
kann oder will und richtig ist auch dass
diese ganze angelegenheit die bürger und
steuerzahler ich weiß das ist ihnen
fremd nicht einen pfennig gekostet hat
nicht einen einzigen euro hat das den
steuerzahler gekostet und da sie jetzt
ja so lautstark ihre künstliche empörung
zenit werden was sie sich ruhig erstmal
die eigene nase denken sie mal ein paar
monate zurück da haben sie kurz vor der
sommerpause mal eben die ohnehin
großzügig bemessene staatliche
parteienfinanzierung um satte 15 prozent
oder 25 millionen euro erhöht einfach
mal so weil ihnen die üppige summe die
sich schon an streichen immer noch nicht
reichen anscheinend weil ihnen ihre
wähler davonlaufen von der spd lange sie
dem bürger noch mal tief in die tasche
alles legal sicher aber ist das
eigentlich auch legitim ist das redliche
umgang mit dem geld der steuerzahler das
die sich gefallen lassen und an die
adresse von herrn k s der sich hier
immer so wunderbar fortwo ja sie
schreien ja die ganze zeit ich finde das
wunderbar was ist mit den direkt spenden
von der rüstungsindustrie an sie von der
hamburger spd im bundestagswahlkampf
2005 was ist damit oder die sache mit
der mal mehr als 1 million euro die als
führender spielhallen konzern im laufe
der jahre verdeckt an union spd fdp und
grüne hat schließen lassen
da wurden nicht nur konkrete
gegenleistungen erwartet sie wollten
darüber reden die ganze zeit sondern wie
lobby möchte auch nicht ohne grund
vermuten in etlichen fällen wohl auch
erbracht und wenn schon immer wieder
haltlos über verdeckte einflussnahme von
außen spekuliert wird wie steht es
eigentlich um die ganz handfesten
einflussnahmen von ihnen werte
genossinnen und genossen wie es immer so
schön sagen der spd ihre partei hält
sich ein unüberschaubares geflecht von
beteiligung und eigentümer schaffen an
zeitungen druckereien service und
vertriebsgesellschaften anzeigenblättern
presse vertrieben dürfen unternehmen
fernseh und videoproduktion
produktionsfirma online und sonstigen
dienstleistern
da wurden in der vergangenheit nicht nur
schon mal gelder hin und her geschoben
da werden auch die bürger immer wieder
hinters licht geführt die glauben sie
würden eine ganz normale lokal oder
regionalzeitung kaufen oder lesen halt
in wahrheit ein parteiblatt von ihnen in
den händen und wenn sie der branche
eingefallen zu und weiß ich schreiben
beispielsweise wenn sie die absenkung
der rentenbeiträge für zeitungszusteller
im minijob im koalitionsvertrag
unterbringen dann sind sie ist der
großunternehmer spd als lobbyist in
eigener sache unterwegs auch ohne
umständliche stein
die flüsse so mit den umständlichen
stränden flüssen haben sie natürlich
trotzdem erfahrungen geht ja noch weiter
wie war das mit den hunderttausenden die
im zuge des baus einer
müllverbrennungsanlage an die kölner spd
gegangen sind was war das oder mit dem
regensburger immobilienunternehmen aus
deren umfeld während des wahlkampfes
2014 dem ortsverband des spd
amtsinhabers eine halbe million
zugeflossen sind und der örtlichen cdu
der örtlichen csu immerhin 90.000 euro
nicht nur gestückelt sondern dazu mit
mitarbeitern als strohmänner wie die
staatsanwaltschaft vermutet das ist ihre
praxis sie wollen über parteispenden
reden also gut reden wir auch über die
schwarzen kassen und das bis heute nicht
aufgeklärt und bin bis system von helmut
kohl
reden wir von den illegalen spenden an
die hessische cdu in den neunzigern und
ihre angeblichen jüdischen vermächtnisse
oder sprechen wir über die jüngste
spendenaffäre der cdu in rheinland-pfalz
dafür die spur des geldes einem dubiosen
ex geheimagenten der im wahlkreis eines
cdu-bundestagsabgeordneten residiert und
offenbar öfter mal unterstützung
benötigt ja und was war mit den
jahrelang spenden von heckler & koch an
den cdu kreisverband in rottweil
was war damit bei großspenden aus
industrie und verbänden ist die cdu
spitzenreiter und auf der äußersten
linken die sich so oft darüber wohl frei
empören geben sie doch einfach mal erst
rechenschaft über das milliarden
vermögen
dass ihre partei als sie noch sed hieß
in jahrzehntelanger diktatur angehäuft
hat ins ausland verschoben
ich weiß das tut weh aber sie wollten es
ja ja ich weiß dass die heulerei es tut
einfach weg ins ausland verschoben
in unternehmen geparkt als darlehen an
einzelne funktionäre verteilt das muss
er sich mal vorstellen einen hohen
millionenbetrag davon ist nämlich immer
noch verschwunden geld das von rechts
wegen dem bürger zusteht wo nicht der
partei die es all die jahre unterdrückt
hat ja wir haben fehler gemacht wir
haben es erkannt und reagiert
zurückgezahlt weit vor dem absolut
inszenierten medienskandal moralische
vorhaltungen müssen wir uns hier von
ihnen überhaupt nicht machen lassen
am wenigsten von ihnen sehr geehrte
damen und herren und kommen sie raus aus
ihren glashäusern und hören sie auf mit
steinen zu werfen die sie nachher selber
treffen machen sie endlich politik für
unser land und für die bürger und machen
sie nicht permanent politik für sich
selber das haben die bürger in unserem
land verdient vielen dank